[Musique]
7h44 très bonne journée à vous tous qui
nous écoutent et alba ventura vous
recevez donc ce matin le président du
parti l'est républicain christian jacob
bonjour christian jacob bonjour
permettez moi de vous lire ces quelques
mots je ne peux pas accepter ce
spectacle de violence qui abaisse notre
pays ce soulèvement partisans et la
violence sociale de ceux qui veulent
allumer partout des feux de haine et de
discorde
chaque fois que la république à semer la
division elle est tombée de toute sa
hauteur comme un mauvais fruits
ces mots vous le savez christian jacob
ils sont signés nicolas sarkozy c'était
à la cérémonie de voeux de romorantin
chez le numéro 2 de votre parti
guillaume pelletier christian jacob ses
mots ils sont dirigés contre ceux qui
manifestent de manière violente contre
les grévistes les plus radicaux ou
contre le pouvoir
empêtré dans sa réforme des retraites
contre emmanuel macron d'abord c'est un
sentiment d'inquiétude de fortes
inquiétudes qui exprime et nicolas
sarkozy et c'est un constat de la
situation aux anges
chacun peut le constater en ce moment là
la société tendu comme elle l'a rarement
été
et et on voit bien cette cette pression
très forte mais ça vient pas de nulle
part
pense qu'il y a tout cas je considère
qu'il ya une responsabilité du
gouvernement elle n'est pas unique parce
que c'est toujours une addition de
différentes fait ou aux circonstances ya
une responsabilité sur une certaine
forme d'arrogance et de mépris dans
l'exercice du pouvoir
c'est à dire que vous comprenez cette
violence non d'abord je la condamne très
clairement très fermement
mais après cherchons les mots si on veut
apporter une solution il faut d'abord
bien bien identifié les les mots et je
reviens là dessus vous savez quand au
lendemain de l'élection présidentielle
président de la république avait dit à
propos de notre dame des landes qu'il
respecterait l'expression populaire le
lendemain on s'aidait tout aux voyous et
aux casseurs à notre dame des landes
lorsque on a eu ensuite cette réaction à
l'égard des mères qui sont les élus des
territoires
ouosso d'arman avait contribué à
alimenter cette polémique sur balances
ton mère lorsque les les députés sont
traités aussi par le mépris le budget
des retraites une réforme des retraites
300 milliards d'euros le budget ne sera
pas étudiée à l'assemblée nationale
c'est du jamais vu
et donc ça veut dire quoi tout cela
favorise tout cela fait qu un maul
prospérer une forme de violence et c'est
à dire que lorsqu'il y à ce mépris ce
manque de considération pour les
partenaires sociaux pour les élus pour
l'expression populaire vous avez des
gens qui se disent mais finalement
est-ce que c'est pas la violence seul
recours
et c'est ça qu'il faut bloquer cette
violence elle est inacceptable et doit
être condamné avec la plus grande
fermeté
l'autorité de l'état doit revenir mais
en même temps que l'autorité de l'état
il faut aussi qu'ils aient des gestes
l'autorité devant 2
ça vient d'où problème d'autorité du
président du ministre de l'intérieur
celui qu'il incarne normalement c'est le
ministre de l'intérieur mais là quand on
voit les chiffres sur le la sécurité
l'explosion de la délinquance
l'explosion sur l'immigration il ya un
vrai sujet sur la place beauvau et sur
le ministre de l'intérieur qui est
qu'ils occupent
mais la responsable ce serait trop
facile de dire c'est uniquement le
ministre de l'intérieur c'est une
volonté politique du président de la
république et du premier ministre
ça va mal finir avait dit nicolas
sarkozy écoutez moi je comprends
l'inquiétude du président parce que
nicolas sarkozy parce que je pense que
jamais on a connu des moments de tension
il ya très longtemps qu'on n'a pas connu
des moments de tension aussi fort la
santé sur l'afficheur tableau cela dit
nicolas sarkozy parce qu'à la fois il
dit ça et en même temps il est jamais
très frontal vis-à-vis du président de
la république il l'aida à la place qui
est la sienne il n'est pas nicolas
sarkozy il n'est pas acteur dans la vie
dans la vie politique mais il a
l'expérience d'un ancien président de la
république d'un ancien ministre de
l'intérieur qui a été confronté à des
moments difficiles
des manifestations y en a eu sous la
droite et y en ait des moments de
tension si mais jamais on a senti un
niveau de violence comment le comme on
le sent aujourd'hui et je pense que il
faut bien prendre l'ensemble des choses
à la fois la nécessité de gestes
d'apaisement de respecter les corps
intermédiaires de respecter les les élus
et puis d'assumer et d'affirmer
l'autorité de l'état
vous attendez un geste du président je
pense que la responsabilité est grande
soler et qu' il peut pas rester
silencieux vis-à-vis de cette de cette
situation on voit bien la manière dont
ils ont tergiversé sur la réforme des
retraites ces pseudo négociation qu'on
n'était pas pendant deux ans et demi
pour une une réforme qui est vidé de son
sens mais en même temps on veut
conserver une certaine forme d'arrogance
calmont également les choses plus
généralement christian jacob sur la
sécurité la délinquance vous en parler
les chiffres sont on peut le dire
catastrophique mais depuis 2002 on a eu
une vingtaine de lois sur la sécurité
et là encore nicolas sarkozy à l'époque
a eu des mots durs une communication
certes très efficace mais les villes non
pardon jamais été nettoyée au quart
cher ou ne se sont pas de débarrasser de
la racaille comme ils disaient oui sauf
que quand on compare les chiffres de la
de la délinquance lorsque nicolas
sarkozy était président de la république
ou était ministre de l'intérieur
est ce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui c'est
sans commune mesure
ça explose de tous les côtés les coups
et blessures sur cette année c'est 8 %
en augmentation depuis l'arrivée
d'emmanuel de macron ses 21 %
d'augmentation
les violences sexuelles c'est 12%
d'augmentation cette année c'était 19%
l'année dernière les homicides ses huit
et demi pour cent jamais il ya eu une
telle explosion des chiffres sur la sur
la délinquance il dois je vous rappeler
que les policiers demandent toujours des
effectifs supplémentaires que vous avez
à l'époque supprimer le sujet sous l'ère
sarkozy l'avait dit un dix mille
suppressions parce qu'il fallait faire
des économies à l'est mais le sujet
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu à coups de
chiffres et d'annonce de policiers
supplémentaires
il se passe pas une semaine sans que le
gouvernement nous annonce des effectifs
supplémentaires
le sujet n'est pas là le sujet c'est la
baisse de l'équipement c'est que les
policiers aujourd'hui travaillent dans
des conditions extrêmement difficiles 6%
de baisse sur le budget de l'équipement
donc arrêtons nous annoncer des chiffres
sur les effectifs le sujet c'est d'abord
que nos policiers soient formés soit
équipée et aussi des rythmes de travail
qui soit adaptée au chapitre de
l'insécurité il ya aussi cette étude
vous savez sur l'antisémitisme 70 % des
juifs de france qui disent avoir été
victime d'antisémitisme
par ailleurs emmanuel macron est en
israël en ce moment à l'occasion des 75
ans de la libération du camp d'auschwitz
mais comme le rappelle le figaro ce
matin christian jacob on a toléré la
tenue de manifestations dans lesquelles
on entend des morts aux juifs
et ça ça s'est passé en france en 2006
en 2010 en 2014
c'est pas nouveau dans celle de cette
insécurité ville elle même et c'est tout
aussi scandaleux c'est ce n'est pas le
fait que ce soit répétitif que ce soit
moins scandaleux et là aussi quand je
parle de l'autorité de de l'état d'aider
condamnation on a été jeudi retrait 13
ans en propositions sur ces sur ces
sujets notamment sa sur les
consultations des sites qui appellent à
la haine et à la violence
les républicains n'ont eu de cesse de
faire des propositions par la voix
d'eric ciotti ou doux de guillaume
larrivé da certains de nos collègues
donc là dessus nous avons été force de
proposition jamais nous n'avons été
entendu voici le reproche que je fais où
et quand je parlais du mépris de ce
gouvernement et du président de la
république c'est que à partir du moment
où on est dans l'opposition de toute
façon on a tort sur tout et les
partenaires sociaux c'est la même façon
si ce mépris permanent fait que ça crée
des tensions parce que les gens se
disent mais bon sang personne n'écoutait
personne n'a entendu christian jacob les
municipales est ce que vous espérez vous
ressourcer à ce moment là après la
présidentielle
après les européennes qui n'ont pas été
terribles pour la partie non non vient
de trois défaites successives
présidentielle législative élections
européennes et pour nous il ya un enjeu
déterminant
à l'occasion de ces élections
municipales je pense que c'est le moment
on pourra remettre le pied sur la terre
ferme pour pouvoir effectivement
rebondir parce que nous avons des des
maires sortants qui sont reconnus dans
le travail qui était le leur au près de
nous de nos codes de nos compatriotes
dans l'exercice de leur mandat de maire
nous avons par ailleurs de bons
candidats et aujourd'hui je suis
effectivement plutôt confiant parce que
c'est une élection qui ne correspond
aussi c'est celle des territoires
vous avez de bons candidats et vous avez
de belles division je pense notamment
dans le cas des plus gros deux candidats
aient l'air maintenant
a marseille deux candidats et leurs
incidences ficek je vous rappelle la
situation de la république en marche
dans dix sept arrondissements de paris
avec l'autorisation des seconds paris
mais c'est pour ça non mais je viens
occasion nous avons un sujet dans un
arrondissement à paris
la république en marche dans dix sept
arrondissements pourquoi on a voulu
reprendre cette décision hier très clair
sur le 15e arrondissement
nous avons un maire en place qui
sollicitait le soutien de sa famille
politique des républicains mais qui
refuse de choisir qui dit coûtait voté
pour moi et je verrai ensuite à qui
j'apporte mes voix l'élection du maire
de paris est dit
ferrante des autres c'est à dire on élit
une liste dans un arrondissement et
ensuite sur cette liste il y a des
conseillers de paris qui eux mêmes
auront à élire le maire implanté le
sujet n'est pas là le sujet c'est la
mairie de paris avait il a souvent rendu
service avec partie non le sujet c'est
la mairie de paris
nous avons dit demander affidés bougeant
à la liste qui conduisent qui s'engage
clairement à soutenir rachida dati
il nous dit votez pour moi une fois que
je serai élu je verrai à qui j'apporte
mes voix si je les apporte à villani 6g
apporte à grimaud ou si je les apporte à
rachida dati ça n'est pas acceptable et
donc j'ai pris la décision de proposer
une nouvelle investiture avec agnès
evren qui est un élu du 15e qui est la
présidente de la fédération des
républicains de paris qui ai je une
jeune femme qui est qui est très engagé
en politique puisque le président de
notre fédération et qui conduira notre
liste de façon à ce que si on était dans
cette situation invraisemblable où dans
le 15e arrondissement de paris si vous
êtes électeur dans le 15e arrondissement
de paris et que vous voulez voter pour
rachida dati et les républicains vous ne
pouvez pas le faire parce que vous ne
savez pas à qui le maire d'un
arrondissement pour tracer voit donc
christian sont rentrés dans le vif et
nous avons tranché les candidats qui
noue des alliances avec le rassemblement
national de marine le pen ou des maires
sortants qui mettent sur leurs listes
des candidats du rassemblement de
national qu'est ce que vous faites vous
les exclus et voulaient sanctionner deux
cas maintenant partir du moment où il ya
une alliance fr à partir du moment où il
ya une alliance avec le front national
moi je suis dans la continuité qui a été
celle de jacques chirac de nicolas
sarkozy de jean-françois copé de laurent
wauquiez
il y à une étanchéité avec le front
national et donc nous n'accepterons
aucune alliance et s'il ya des des
alliances les gens qui les font n'ont
plus rien à faire dans notre famille
politique c'est aussi clair que ça merci
christian jacob sur les retraites
violence quand gouvernement calmont les
choses affirme christian jacob qui
constate je cite une forme d'arrogance
et de mépris de l'exécutif l'intégralité
de l'entretien comme chaque jour est à
retrouver sur le site rtl